the actual payments under this proposal
it would be up to 1.2 million dollars
reparations are not only morally
justifiable but they have the potential
to address long-standing racial
disparities and inequality I've already
explained why reparations are a
ludicrous morally incoherent idea we
cannot allow people to cash in on the
injustices committed against their
ancestors because if we did that then
everyone all people on Earth should get
a check because we all have a suffering
in our bloodline you especially can't
play this game with slavery of all
things given that slavery is a global
sin and there is no race there is no
Group which is innocent of it Africa
enthusiastically practiced slavery until
the late 20th century African nations
and tribes that caught and captured and
sold the slaves into the transatlantic
slave trade so a black person in America
today may be the descendant of us of
slaves he may also be the descendant of
slave Traders he may be both and many of
us are likely both if you go back far
enough